hey everybody it's Charlie! did one of you ask
for a Nightwing movie? because we totally
just got a Nightwing movie!
let's just say that after running this
team for a year
I'm peckish for a little action it's really
great news all around everybody's so
happy about Nightwing getting his own
movie so i'll explain what's going on
with the dce you their schedule to like
19 plus films they could do but a lot of
those aren't confirmed yet they just
have to do with the success of the film
to precede them so like this year is
very important for them
Wonder Woman has to do really well
Justice League has to do really well or
it could change all the other movies
that are coming after with the exception
of like Aquaman that's already in
production right now so if you're new to
the channel you have no idea what's
going on i do DC videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything I
even have a dedicated DC day there's
giveaways that i'll explain at the end
of the video too because there's some
special stuff happening but pull out
your fanboy cards so they confirmed news
is that Matt Reed is going to direct the
Batman movie and they're doing a live
action Nightwing movie with Dick Grayson
with the director of the lego batman
movie so if you haven't seen that movie
i recommend you go check it out even if
it's not your usual thing it's actually
a lot of fun of your big Batman fan but
as far as casting goes when it's going
to drop nobody knows a whole lot about
the knightly movie they just announced
that they're officially starting to
develop it so they found the director
now they're going to start looking at
actors are going to start looking at
scripts so it's gonna take him a while
to work through that so don't expect to
hear a lot about that before comic-con
so like I said 19 plus films just expect
them to announce like what's coming next
when we get to Comic Con because they'll
be rolling into justice Lee in warner
brothers it is good at anything
it is amazing at marketing its film so
they're going to bring it to comic-con
this year i know a lot of you are asking
about why they didn't talk about Batman
when they released the news about the
Batman movie so i'll address that but
here's this late of all the movies they
have coming starting with Wonder Woman
so wonder woman coming June second
Justice League coming november
seventeenth probably zack snyder's the
last film in the dce you i think you
know everybody's wondering if people are
leaving like Ben Affleck wants to leave
the only person that I think that is
done in the dce you as of Justice League
is going to be Zack Snyder and he might
like to
some advising for behind-the-scenes but
he's not going to be directing the next
justice league movie after that then
there's Aquaman october fifth 2018 then
the Flash movie sometime 2019 because
that probably won't go into production
till way later this year it's going to
take them at least six months to shoot
it and then another six months on top of
that to finish post-production and get
it ready so we're talking about 20 19
the Batman movies the next one after
that so it could crawl in at the end of
2018 but i'm thinking closer to like
early 2019 because they're talking about
making a couple edits to the script
taking a couple more passes at it
because Matt read the new director is
also going to be a producer on the film
but it didn't say anything about him
writing the script so even if they don't
change a lot
Deathstroke still in there still a big
character in the movie they'll still
take a couple passes that it will take a
couple more weeks and then they'll
probably announce the shooting date
later this year and they'll be like okay
we're going to start casting these other
characters here's what's going on in
because obviously they announced the
Nightwing movie i totally think that
dick racin will get a cameo like the way
to the very end of production because
it'll take them awhile to figure out
what is going on with the knightly movie
they probably have an idea but like it
took awhile to figure the Batman script
out it's going to take awhile to figure
the Nightwing script out so they're not
going to need their dick grayson for a
while and it takes them six months to
shoot the Batman that they could even
wait till next year to cast it but again
they might have some more news about
that at comic-con Marvel's run into that
problem too like when they were looking
for dr. strange they really wanted
Benedict Cumberbatch they really wanted
to announce that Robert Downey jr. was
going to be in both of the Avengers
movies way couple years ago but he
hadn't signed his contract yet so they
could announce it at comic-con so a lot
of times it just depends on when people
have actually signed their contracts but
either way Batman moving along as
planned the next film after that is
green lantern corps that's 2020 release
date now like the armie hammer was one of
my picks for Nightwing but the thing is is
that reportedly Warner Brothers wants
him for the Green Lantern Corps movie so
he would be there Hal Jordan and he does
look a little bit more like Hal Jordan
then he looks like Dick Grayson so the
pics are still wide open
does the sideboard movie which was
originally set for 2020 but they might
change that they might just make him a
bigger character during the Flash movie
and not give him a spin
off movie depending on how these are the
movie through there's the Suicide Squad
sequel which they just announced
mel gibson is supposedly going to direct it
but they haven't officially confirmed
that yet
then there's the gotham city sirens
movie that david ayers directing they
don't have a date for that yet they just
said they're actually working on it
there's a dead shot movie that they're
supposedly developing for Will Smith no
word on that it's just that they're
working on it behind the scene so it
might come together the man of steel 2
movie is only listed as being an active
development there's no release date it
would probably fall sometime after the
second justice league movie if it ends
up happening
Nightwing just got announced you guys
know about that the shazam movie was
announced the little while ago but it
looks like the other movie because
there's two shows and movies one of them
going to be a black adam movie and the
other one's going to be ashes a movie
like if you refer to black adam and the
hero but he's a villain what that means
for the movie is really in our
interpretation and who we deem a hero
course like Adams mythology is a villain
or he could be considered an antihero or
for some he's a hero to some who has a
black heart like me again i love the
fact story that he started off as a
slave and he was held down and i think
when that kind of backstory about a man
is held down and he rises up out of that
to become greater and then dealing with
conflict the pain of losing his family
it's dark but it also adds to the
gravity and adds to the weight of the story
so what does it mean for the movie it
means that the movie is going to be
fantastic and it means that it's going
to be badass
and it means to me he's a hero because they
have the rock and he has such a hot star
right now the Black Adam movie is
probably going to come first and then
we'll introduce dishes and character
during that they announced the doug
liman Justice League dark live-action
movie the one the guillermo del toro
been trying to get off the ground for a
long time
that's still in development there's a
Lobo movies it's also in development and
in the second justice league movie which
used to be a zack snyder think but
that's probably not going to go down now
they'll probably announce a new director
sometime in the next couple years but
those are all the movies that DC has in
the dce you release schedules that it's
actively developing the other big one
that everyone's asking about now is Teen
Titans because they have the
Dick Grayson Nightwing if they want to if
everything goes according to plan
they can totally do team Titans it's a
big reality but there's nothing
confirmed they haven't announced
anything about it
that sounds like a comic con think like
hey you see all this does is going on
like if everything goes well this year
will be like look at all these other
amazing movies that were developing now
based on successful properties so a lot
of that just depends on how successful
the dce you is this year because
bringing it back around to ben affleck
Batman everybody's wondering is he
leaving you know what's up with the
rumors so the thing is is that he is
probably going to stay all the way
through Justice League no matter what
happens even if he does want to leave
but there's just a lot of things
pointing towards him staying you know
gut feeling is the East days through
that second justice league film assuming
that they actually end up making it now
anything could happen down the road but
the thing is is that Ben Affleck right
now is kind of in movie jail his last
movie that he directed and started did
not do very well so he's a big hit which
is the Batman movie it's a guaranteed
hit
even if it's just an okay movie but
after justice league comes out and if he
does really want to leave they'll
probably wait till after the Batman
movie comes out late 2018 early 2019 so
even if he did leave the role as Batman
he will still be Batman for a couple
more years for a couple more movies
remember they love that man they put
them in all the movies he's in like a
billion different comic books right now
in the reason that they didn't meant
and having that press release is because
it's all about getting credit is all
about Matt Reeves so the whole reason that
he actually walked from talks briefly
like people are like oh my God he's
bailed he's not going to do the movie
the whole reason for that is because his
agent just asked for a giant paycheck
like 10-15 million dollars and warner
brothers is like whoa you know pump the
brakes on that we're not gonna pay you
that much money so he's really good
Hollywood agent that represents a lot of
the other DC directors did the Power
Move thing where you use the press
against the studio so director leaves
and it makes it look like the movies in
trouble so Warner Brothers panics and
it's like okay let's make a deal
so it's not getting as much money but he
has a producer credit so he's going to
get a lot more on the back end it's all
a money thing it's really just a
negotiating tactic
so the movie itself is totally fine
don't worry about it
Nightwing is going to be a lot of fun to
follow through the rest of the years
I've probably a bunch more news about it
as we get closer to comic-con but let me
know what do you guys think about all
this i think it's going to be pretty
crazy this year but i think the nightly
news is Batman news is enough to turn
people around like we're even getting
ready for a Justice League trailer
pretty soon it's not going to come this
month but it'll probably be some time
before wonder woman hits theaters so i'm
guessing sometime in April but will
probably hear more about that in a
little while so what's going to happen
is is I will have a dedicated DC video
day it sounds like mondays are
going to be marvel stuff so i think
what's going to happen is it will be tuesdays
because i already do flash stuff
or it'll be like fridays or saturdays so
you guys can let me know which day you
want to make DC day there's a new round
of the injustice 2 giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment about batman
Nightwing stuff on this video
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Tony Adams please private message
me on the back end of my channel so i can
get your contact details
what's going to happen next is is it
star wars day tomorrow there's a whole
bunch of Star Wars news but i also got
some Deadpool x-force that's crazy so
i'll be posting that too and there's
that crazy injustice trailer so those
will be the next videos that I post but
i'll update the schedule as I post those
new videos so let you guys know what's
going to be happening this weekend all
the craziness is going to be great for
you way that you can click here to
rewatch that Thor Ragnarok teaser and you
can click here
to learn all about Aquaman thank you
so much for watching let's high five,
I'll see you guys in the next video